thank you very much thank you president
Trump is not ready to call it a
breakthrough but he is optimistic that
the offer from North Korea on talks to
end its nuclear program may bear fruit I
think that they are sincere in a joint
appearance with Swedish prime minister
Stephane Lavigne president Trump made a
joke when asked what brought North Korea
to this point me know I think that
nobody got that the president did take
credit for the harsh sanctions that he
says helped bring North Korea around he
also said the u.s. helped make the
recent South Korean Olympics a success
and had praised for North Korea's
participation
I thought North Korea was terrific they
came out they went into the Olympics
they went in with good spirit they did
well it's let's see if we can carry it
over we may carry it over it may not
very it's a very tenuous situation good
it's gonna be very interesting to see
what happens president Trump said
several times we'll see what happens
with North Korea former UN Ambassador
John Bolton believes the promise of
talks could be just a ruse by the north
to buy time the only thing North Korea
is serious about is getting deliverable
nuclear weapons and by all accounts they
are very close to achieving an objective
they've been after for 25 years so why
do they want to talk now to divert our
attention to get us and meshed yet again
in negotiations to get across that
finish line the threat of punitive
tariffs on steel and aluminum was high
on the agenda and talks between the
president and swedish prime minister
levine carrying a message from the
european union that any american tariffs
would be met with penalties against US
goods made in heavily republican
districts like motorcycles jeans and
bourbon the European Union has been
particularly tough on the United States
they make it almost impossible for us to
do business with them and yet they send
their cars and everything else back into
the United States and they can do
whatever they'd like but if they do that
then we put a big tax of 25% on their
cars and believe me they won't be doing
it very long
do you avoid this escalating into a
trade war we'll have to see you know
when we're behind on every single
country trade wars aren't so bad
do you understand what I mean by that
when we're down by 30 billion 40 billion
60 billion a hundred billion the trade
war hurts them doesn't hurt us we're
gonna straighten it out and we'll do it
in a in a very loving way you'll be a
loving loving way they'll like us better
and they will respect us much more when
asked how forceful the message he
carried to the president was the Prime
Minister deflected I fully understand
and respect the president's view that we
have to look after his own country the
country that you're leading I understand
that fully that's my primarily task as
well but for me leading a small country
depending on on open trade we the best
way for us is to do that with others
President Trump also weighed in on
recent staff changes at the White House
and his tweet this morning that I still
have some people that I want to change
always seeking perfection
there is no chaos only great energy
there'll be people that change they
always change sometimes they want to go
out and do something else but they all
want to be in the White House so many
people want to come in I have a choice
of anybody I could take any position in
the White House and I'll have a choice
of the 10 top people that's very ironic
that when President Trump made that
statement he knew that Gary Cohen was
already on his way out the door but the
president didn't allude to that at the
time there's so much for all of the talk
that Gary Cohen was going to replace
John Kelly as the chief of staff here at
the White House there was also some
thought among some people at the White
House that as soon as there was a
cabinet vacancy the Gary Cohen could be
tapped to replace that person we're told
that Gary Cohen was so well thought of
here at the White House that he could
have filled out a number of different
cabinet positions but again a bill it
looks like Gary Cohen is going to lose
the argument over tariffs because the
President did seem to indicate today at
that press conference that he is going
to go ahead with those Peters of tariffs
on foreign aluminum and steel